a lunar eclipse happens when the earth
blocks some or all of the sun's direct
light from reaching the moon
this cosmic event only takes place
during a full moon
which happens once every 29 and a half
days
or the length of one full orbit of the
moon around the earth
[Music]
so why don't we have an eclipse every
month
the moon's orbit is tilted a few degrees
in relation to the earth
so the earth moon and sun don't always
align
when the earth does eclipse the sun it
casts two types of shadows on the moon a
larger shadow known as the penumbra
and a smaller darker shadow known as the
umbra
there are three types of lunar eclipses
the first is a total lunar eclipse when
the sun moon and earth are in perfect
alignment and the moon falls within the
earth's umbral shadow
total lunar eclipses are the most
striking of the three types because they
turn the moon a sunset red
while shorter blue wavelengths of light
are scattered outward by the earth's
atmosphere longer red wavelengths are
refracted or bent inward toward the moon
making it appear red
the brightness of the moon's red glow
depends upon how much dust and clouds
are in the earth's atmosphere
following volcanic activity ash can
block out enough light to render the
moon a darker red or even near black
a partial lunar eclipse the second type
occurs when the earth moon and sun don't
perfectly align so only part of the moon
passes into earth's umbra
earth's shadow appears very dark on the
side of the moon facing earth
[Music]
last a penumbral lunar eclipse occurs
when the moon passes through earth's
penumbral shadow
the event is so subtle that most people
don't even notice
the moon will appear just slightly
darker than normal
lunar eclipses occur up to three times a
year and can be observed from the entire
night time half of the earth unlike
during a solar eclipse it's safe to look
at the moon with the naked eye during a
lunar eclipse
it is only because of the distances of
the sun and moon from the earth that we
are able to witness total lunar eclipses
as the moon inches away from the earth
each year
one day billions of years from now the
moon will be too far away to fall
completely within earth's umbral shadow
until then we can occasionally enjoy
seeing our own planet's shadow cast upon
the largest object in the night sky
[Music]
you